rather than trying to mimic how the
brain works it's more being inspired by
how the brain works this is true for
neural networks for example they're also
based on how our brain processes
information it doesn't mean that it's an
exact copy of how the brain works and
it's not to go I mean machines have
different capabilities so it's not so
much about trying to mimic exactly human
brain rather than being inspired you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
if you've ever watched king of Kong
Fistful of quarters you know what a big
deal it is to beat a video arcade game
that was designed not to lose enter dr.
harm Van Zion and a team of machine
learning researchers from Microsoft
maluma in Montreal they took on Miss
pac-man and won today we'll talk to her
about his work in reinforcement learning
the inspiration for hybrid reward
architecture visit a few islands of
tractability and get an inside look at
the science behind the AI defeat of one
of the most difficult video arcade games
around that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast harm give our listeners a brief
description of the kind of work you do
so I work on reinforcement learning
which is a subclass of machine learning
as focuses on learning good behaviors so
it's a very powerful method you can use
it in many different instances but it's
still a lot of research to make sure
that it can be applied in its broadest
setting so we were working on those
challenges to remove those obstacles so
it can be applied in a very broad way
why is machine learning and particularly
reinforcement learning such an important
field in artificial intelligence so with
more and more data you can just build
more and more complex systems so when
your system to become more complex at a
certain moment you can just not code
everything by hand anymore but you
wanted to learn automatically for
example classifying images to build a
classifier that can recognize certain
objects if you would do it at the hand
it would be very complex so if you do it
by machine learning you can
automatically learn it so that this
helps you to build a very complex
classifier that you couldn't otherwise
and code behind and so with
reinforcement learning is a similar
thing but it's then about behaviors in
behaviors it's about taking actions so
you can for example it's using alphago
you're you're able to build a go player
that is much stronger than humans
because it learns automatically you can
you can build something
much better than humans one of your big
achievements recently is beating the
game of MS pacman why are video games so
suitable for exploring artificial
intelligence well they're suitable
because they give you a very controlled
environment to test certain ideas so if
you're dealing with applications in the
real world you then have to tackle the
full complexity of your problem all at
once
whereas in in a game you can play with
how complex you make your problem and
it's a more controlled environment to
test certain ideas also because you can
run it faster than real time for example
so you can very quickly have a very
quick turnaround time for building
algorithms yes so you're running the
game at a faster speed than the game
normally goes yeah exactly
so for example if we take again the
example of go as an example so if you
would play go in real time it's a very
slow game in yuuki maybe a game lasts an
hour or two hours but if you play as in
an artificial environment you can run it
must faster so you can play many many
games in the same amount of time that
you would play a single game in in real
time so so that can yeah it can give you
a big speed-up in a scenario but miss
pac-man for example which is a different
kind of a game obviously it's a video
game that moves super fast to begin with
is this the same sort of incremental
speed increase relevant there yeah I
mean because you always want to go
faster and so respect me we can run much
faster than the real time we can run it
maybe 30 or 40 times as fast as real
time so it means that your total
computation time if in the real time it
would take a month if it's 30 times as
far as to take you a single day so it
makes a big difference well and this is
where machines are more capable than we
are currently in terms of speed of
processing and calculation and things
like that yeah it's interesting because
if you look at games then there are a
couple of aspects where machine really
have an advantage and or a couple of
aspects where you must have an advantage
so if you have a game that is
challenging mainly because it requires a
very high reaction time then that would
be a game where machines naturally have
an advantage
first this on the other hand you have
games where that really require
long-term reasoning and those are games
that are very suitable for humans but
these are much harder for machines yeah
I'm wondering if we can make them feel
inferior but I don't I don't think they
have those kinds of feelings at the at
the current time not yet right listen as
a level set kind of talk to me a little
bit about the broader world of machine
learning right now and differentiate
some of the concepts with learning you
have different problems basically so so
the three big ones are supervised
learning unsupervised learning and
reinforcement learning so those are
really problem definitions for example
reinforcement learning tackles the
problem of an agent that interacts with
an environment and if you compare that
with deep learning for example so deep
learning is really it's not so much a
problem definition as it is a technique
so it's a particular technique to do
function approximation in particular
having many different layers of neural
networks for example so it's a technique
you can use on these different problem
instances so if you combine deep
learning with reinforcement learning you
get something called deep reinforcement
learning and it just means that you're
tackling the problem of reinforcement
learning using a function approximation
that uses deep learning what's hot right
now or are they all sort of are there
areas in machine learning that are
really interesting to a lot of people
yeah so so deep learning really had a
big boom a couple of years ago so that
it's like super hot right now it had
like a long history like in the eighties
it was also popular patinas kind of died
down again and so at the most recent
boom was a couple of years ago when he
discovered how he would build much
deeper networks and much more powerful
networks deep learning has received a
big boom very recently and I think
reinforcement learning is just on the
brink of breaking true the most recent
two years a lot of companies have become
very interested in reinforcement
learning as well so I think that's the
next big thing you know it seems like as
you as you say it it makes me think that
the booms
when a particular research or a group of
researchers or even inventors if you
will make a breakthrough in it and then
everyone pays attention and it's like
hey that's that's new that's interesting
let's go on that thread and where are
you with reinforcement learning in that
process are you still in the kind of
their research breakthrough phase so in
terms of maturity I think it's much less
mature it's much more still in the
research phase than something like deep
learning so there's still a lot of
problem instances that we cannot solve
yet or not solve wet well yet so there
are a couple of islands of tractability
that within certain problem instances in
reinforcement learning that we can solve
so in particular if you consider the
bend the problem which is a special case
of a reinforcement learning problem that
is one that we can do very well and it
supplies for example in ad placement so
placing s on a showing s on the website
that can be modeled as a bender problem
and so it's being used there in real
products so address some subset of
reinforcement learning we can already
use we can do well and using real
products but for the most part is still
a resource effort right not infancy
necessarily but certainly not mature
yeah absolutely yeah did you say islands
of practablity yeah so just certain
certain problem instances that that we
have a good handle on okay yeah I think
I've been stuck on an island of
intractability before but anyway okay
[Music]
when we talked before you said your work
encompasses computer science and
neuroscience in essence you're drawing
on theories of how the human brain works
how are you applying these theories to
your work with machines so I would more
see it as rather than trying to mimic
how the brain works it's more being
inspired by how the brain works
this is true for neural networks for
example they're also based on how our
brain processes information but it
doesn't mean that it's an exact copy of
how the brain works and that that's not
a go I mean machines have different
capabilities so it's not so much about
trying to mimic exactly the human brain
rather than being inspired that also
holds for certain algorithms and
reinforcement learning it's more being
inspired by how we think decision-making
in humans work and trying to make an
exact copy of that yeah yeah yeah that's
interesting well speaking of inspiration
how did you come up with the idea of
hybrid reward architecture what was the
inspiration behind that so so the
inspiration really came from how humans
cooperate to build great products for
example if you have a smartphone it's a
great piece of technology many many
people were involved in building it and
there is not really a single person that
knows how to make a smartphone but it's
really the group of first and all of
them that each have their own expertise
that know how to make a smart phone so
we wanted to build something similar
where if he trying to solve a very
complex task to have a bunch of
different artificial agents that work
together and each agent is focused on a
different aspect of the task so each
agents has a different expertise and
then by combining those agents in a
particular way they show an overall
behavior that is very intelligent so
it's kind of the distributed expertise
model of business as it were right but
only with artificial intelligence agents
within a program yes that's right yeah
so let's talk about that for a second
because when we were talking about HR a
before you mentioned the importance
because you've got these agents acting
individually you've programmed them to
do
specific tasks but then there's a
necessity like there isn't a in a
business for a boss to make a decision
and so explain that how that works with
inside this hybrid were like
architecture HR a particularly with the
MS pacman task right so we want all
those agents to only care about terror
specific problem and not worry about how
to collaborate with other agents so we
have a hierarchical structure where at
the bottom you have all those little
agents that take care of their little
problem that they need to solve so in
the case of reinforcement learning in
the case of miss pac-man
the problem that you ultimately want to
solve is you want to find a behavior or
policy so you want to learn what action
to take given a certain screen image so
so each of those little agents computes
a certain preference given the current a
screen image creates a preference over
the different available actions given
its specific goals
so each agents has a different goal and
goal can be something right so in case
of miss Batman you have all these
fellows that are on the screen so a
specific goal would be to go to one
particular palette so the agent that is
responsible for that whose expertise is
going to that dalit tries to create a
preference over the current actions and
so the action that brings it as quickly
as possible to this fellows who have the
highest preference and so all these
agents and you have more than hundred 50
of those they all communicate their
preferences through Q values to a top
agent and then the top agents kind of
combines all these preferences into a
single action in the combination it
looks not just at how many agents want
to go in a certain direction but also
how important a particular agent is to
put it differently how badly a
particular agent wants to take it action
and so certain actions as going to
appellate are less important than trying
to avoid ghosts because if you run into
a ghost you die which is very bad so the
agent that doesn't want to go to run
into a ghost
his preference is much much stronger for
trying to avoid that Ghost than an agent
responsible
for going to a Tallis so the top agent
looks that's the number of agents that
want to go in a certain direction and
also how important these agents the
number and intensity of the reading
distance that's right so the I see dead
people agent is going to get more
attention than they I see food pellet
agent it's gonna get more attention if
the ghost is very close if it's far away
then it doesn't matter that much so Dan
his preference is not that strong okay
so that makes a difference the ghost
could be right around the corner or the
Josephine and it's very important to
take the right action and then it has a
very strong intensity whereas if the
ghost is far away then its intensity is
much lower and then maybe fruit as close
as a higher intensity so on that same
sort of topic in the paper on HRA and
reinforcement learning you said the best
results were achieved when the AI agent
acted egotistically or selfishly and
left it to the top aggregating agent to
make the best move I mean seriously that
sounds like my family when we're growing
up you know it's the kids each arguing
for their own case and then dad finally
saying okay Gretchen you get it well
yeah so and you can imagine if you have
different experts that you want each
expert we're really good at its
particular job so it's really only
trying to care about its particular job
for example and then it's the top agent
that listens to all of those things and
makes the final decision let's talk
about that for a second because that to
me and we alluded to it earlier kind of
this divide and conquer and this is kind
of a new thing in terms of breaking big
problems down into smaller sections
assigning them and then sort of tackling
the problems that way right how is that
faring in in research that you're doing
and in any others that are kind of
moving in that direction as well so
there's quite some research in trying to
solve a solve a problem using multiple
agents it's always about breaking down a
problem but it is very challenging to
find an architecture that can do that in
a good way so nice
and good policy you can learn is in a
stable way and efficiently so you can
build many different
that somehow break up a problem but to
find like a good one is actually very
challenging so that that's also what we
spend most of our time with on this
research was finding the right way to
have these agents work together so if if
miss pac-man was a kind of a big
achievement and it really was I mean
it's a hard hard hard game with what you
did to conquer that game where could you
see it being used in the real world
where might you try it in a more sort of
practical application yeah I mean
obviously the real world extremely
complex so anything in the real world
you want to kind of break it down yeah
so this particular technique of learning
very intelligent behaviors I mean you
could think of for example a really
smart cortana for example proactive
personal agents because if you interact
with an agent it's it's you have to take
into account actions you have to trade
our immediate versus the future things
that happen immediately and yeah I would
say the real world is really complex and
you want to break it down so it has it
has transferability just how you bring
that into these other scenarios is the
next maybe one of the next steps in the
research so the other question we talked
about this before and I've talked about
it with quite a few people in in your
field
this hybrid reward architecture and
reinforcement learning is considered an
important step towards the path towards
artificial general intelligence right as
opposed to artificial intelligence which
is present in a lot of things as we know
it now talk a little bit about the
difference between those two concepts
right so so the difference is really
about being good in one particular
problem being really good in one
particular thing versus being good in
many different things at the same time
and kind of combining things with each
other so humans have very good
general intelligence so that they can do
many different tasks versus right now
like a lot of AI is very specialized so
they are good in one particular team but
nothing else hmm
so to go towards going to general AI is
trying to create system that just like
humans can do many many different teams
it can easily switch between tasks yeah
and one of the things I've read about
the goal his machines that can think and
reason and communicate with humans like
humans yeah I mean that's the ultimate
dream right so if you can communicate
with your computer for example just in
the same way that we are communicating
now it could make things so much easier
because like the world becomes more and
more complex and if you have like a
device that can deal with the complexity
but it's at the same time you can
interact with it with in a very easy way
that can be really powerful what are you
working on right now so yeah like I said
it's trying to remove obstacles trying
to build better RL methods that are can
be applied to bigger problems a lot has
to do with scalability around works
really great on some restricted
instances so those islands of
tractability I talked about earlier
trying to increase those islands you're
working with a group of people are there
separate threads or I should say sort of
lines of inquiry that you guys are
dividing and conquering on do you work
with teams that try to work on a
particular problem so if you talk about
Microsoft Research maluma and yeah we
have different teams they are working on
different problems so one team works on
machine reading comprehension for
example another team works on dialogue
and then we have my team it works on
reinforcement learning so within like
Microsoft for uses maluma we have
different teams working on different
things and then within the reinforcement
learning group we also have a couple of
projects that we're focusing on we try
to set high goals and those have to be
tackled by by groups of people you can't
solve them on your own so we really try
to think well about
what are the important problems why do
we want to solve and then try to create
interest among multiple people so you
can actually make some progress there so
outside of Microsoft maluma and this
sort of broader research horizon are
there other interesting things going on
with reinforcement learning so so there
are many different active areas of
research within reinforcement learning
there is a only a few islands of
tractability that we can tackle right
now and those are things like
exploration efficient expiration option
discovery representation learning
generalization so there's a whole range
of different active areas of research
and we are working on some of them
another harm what inspired you to get
into this I have a background in Applied
Physics and if you look at physics as a
field then it's a couple of hundred
years old if you compare artificial
intelligence with physics it's a really
new field it's maybe 50 years old or
something
so it's an really exciting area to do
research in it could have such a big
impact on our society if you can
actually well solve general artificial
intelligence for example if we would
solve it completely it would completely
change our society but even if you make
step towards that it can already have a
really big impact so it's exciting in
two ways it's from a research
perspective it's exciting because it's a
new field compared to the different
sciences and it can have what a massive
impact in the world so those two things
is what makes it really exciting for me
and you were that kind of kid growing up
like what can I discover what can i how
can I change the world I was always
interested in in research so it took me
a while before finding where the right
type of research I guess the better from
start I've always been very research he
I guess yeah even as a child yes what
kind of research did you do when you
were young well so for example different
kinds of puzzles I was always interested
in different kinds of puzzles what they
do now is it's kind of a similar thing
solving
but then must harder puzzles yeah I see
what I do right now kind of similar of
what I did when I was 10 years old just
at a different level exponentially
different yeah yeah do you see a lot of
talent coming up in universities whether
it's in Europe or here or Canada that
are ready to take the baton and and run
in this field yeah I mean all across the
world I think a is getting more and more
popular at universities as well I think
here in Canada were really at the
forefront so we have some great
universities here where some of these
techniques deep learning but also
reinforcement learning that came from
the universities here in Canada feels
like the right place to be well it
sounds like you are in the right place
and we're excited to watch as this field
continues to grow and change the world
harm thanks for joining us today
yeah thank you very much
to find out more about dr. Harmon
science and the groundbreaking work
going on at Microsoft my Liuba visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]